[music playing]
- All right.
We got a big ass spot right
here, except for this thing.
What is this white thing?
A sign used to hang
from it and rotate.
We can get rid of it?
- You good with that?
- Yeah.
Taking it down?
Yeah.
The ceiling?
There's no other place for it.
Painting on the
ceiling, I don't even
think Danny is going to notice.
I bet he can walk right
through that door,
right up to Shane, say hello and
everything, and not even notice
it's there.
Gentleman's bet?
How am I going to
do a gentleman's bet?
I'm not a gentleman.
OK, you want to bet that the
boss walks through the door
and doesn't even notice it?
I don't do well on bets.
I never do, but I do have a
lot of confidence in myself.
What are you going to
bet me that he's not
going to see this monstrous,
beautiful painting on
the ceiling that's all lit up?
All right.
We're in a tattoo shop.
Yeah.
If he walks right past that
painting, notices nothing,
you gotta get my
name tattooed on you.
[laughing]
And if he notices, and if
he notices, which I know
he won't, he'll
walk right past it,
I'll get your name
tattooed on me.
I'll even do the tattoo.
Oh, you're going to be sorry.
You saw that, Shane, right?
- Yep, witnessed him.
- Walk.
This is him.
Hey, Shane, how you doing?
Got it right there.
Don't worry.
Nobody walks up like this.
He's going to.
See you later, brother.
Later.
Go, get, go.
He's going to love it.
It's a waste of time.
What's up, Danny?
What's going down?
You guys tell me, man.
It's my day off, you
guys are telling me, come
on down to the tattoo shop.
I'm sensing something
wonderful up in my head.
[laughing]
I have excellent peripheral.
He didn't even look at it.
How did you look us
in the eyes and you
notice that on your ceiling?
- Awesome.
First of all, before
you even get to that,
we wanted to show
our gratitude for you
letting us get our fresh,
beautiful ink on our arms.
- Thank you.
- There is art for art.
OK.
You gave us some?
So we gave you some.
This art over
my head right now?
- Beautiful art.
- Really?
When am I allowed to look at it?
Well, I mean, it's
your tattoo shop.
You're the boss.
You can look at it
whenever you want.
Oh, my.
[music playing]
Are you kidding me?
We wanted something
that screamed, vampire.
Dude, that is so, so wicked.
I do have to admit, that's
got Mike written all over it.
The depth of it is
unbelievable and
the originality of using the
mouth as a whole other scene
is so wicked.
I mean, you've got eyes
that are actual 3D eyes.
The eyes move.
It's crazy.
They kind of follow
you, don't they?
This is one of
your best pieces.
I think it is.
And it looks
great in here, man.
People are going to
trip out on that.
And if I'm going to lose
a bet, I'd lose to this.
Yeah, let's get
back to this bet.
So the bet was, if you
walked through the shop
and did not notice the painting
way up there on the ceiling,
Mike would get my name
tattooed on his foot.
But if you noticed
it right off the bat,
Brian would get Mike's
name tattooed on his foot.
And you said you're going
to get his name and his face?
And his face.
If I'm going to lose,
I'm going to lose big.
Yeah, first shoot I
do, I'm wearing my horns.
[laughing]
He's getting that picture.
OK.
Well, bro, hey man,
you made that bet.
I figured you'd know
that I would notice that.
I just can't believe
you took this bet.
So to me, this is hilarious.
When does this happen?
Before it gets too
late, go into it.
- Dive right into it.
- I think we should.
Start getting you set up.
Get your foot shaved,
because I have no doubt you
have hair on the bottom of it.
You mean today?
Yeah, man, today.
I'm certain.
- Get your shoes off.
No, get off my shoe.
I know people here,
they're really good.
You've got other clientele.
He's got other
clientele before you.
You agreed to the bet.
Man, it's just Mike's
face, so you know,
it's going to take
Dave a minute.
We could have done
this some other day.
It's just going to
be a smiley face.
[laughing]
This is going to hurt
so bad when you see it
because it's really accurate.
[laughing]
I can't believe
you're making me do it.
Dave is arguably one of
the greatest tattoo artists
that you ever would've
met in your life.
That's not helping.
- How's that feeling?
- It hurts.
You're shaking the artist.
You're going to ruin
my beautiful face.
You know, I always say
how Mike gets under my skin,
well, now he's
there permanently.
I can't even die to
get away from this guy.
This is hilarious.
I can't believe
this happened today.
That and I can't believe--
See, it's a good day.
--that you just get your foot
drilled with horny Mike's face.
Good luck, man.